hello you today I am making this video
because because I'm feeling happy and I
want you to feel happy too I am NOT some
sort of happiness guru I don't have the
key to unlock happiness but these are
just the tips that I use to kind of be
happy or while I didn't really notice I
was doing at the time but it's totally
worked and I hope it can work for you as
well if you're feeling down first of all
I'll start off with why should you be
happy and this sounds like a really
stupid question because of course
everyone wants to be happy but sometimes
we just forget that that's what we
should be or what we want to be because
we're too busy focusing on other things
like perhaps we have big aspirations for
our career or we have to reach a
deadline I don't know we have to do
really well for some homework and we
just kind of forget to do the small
things that will keep our well-being in
check what so wait you feel over if a
longer being away from people and kind
of blocking yourself inside not gonna
help with your mental state you might
start seeing things talking to yourself
like me but honestly you're not going to
be good to anyone if your mental
well-being it's not good it's going to
come out in the work that you produce
you're gonna find it very hard to
motivate yourself you'll probably just
like a lot of the stuff that you're
doing anyway even though you're locking
yourself away to get it done so it is
important that you look after yourself
and your your mental health as well as
your physical health so yes do it make
time for send me on from that remember
that we're all human if you feel a bit
blue or upset you're not being stupid
your not being whiny you're not being
over emotional well you might be but
emotions are fine and being emotional is
a good thing it means that you're a
human you are not her robot and that is
beautiful us as humans were so complex
and do you really want to live your life
in one mental state for the full time no
you might want to be happy all the time
but actually if you think about it I
don't know well actually I forget about
that question it's the way that life is
you're gonna have up so you're gonna
have downs and acknowledging that it's
okay to be down is the first step to
become
me back up the top again once you've
acknowledged this go talk to someone you
bound to have a close family member some
friends someone who really cares about
you and someone who actually does want
to listen to your problems you might
think that you're burdening them with
your own issues and only you can solve
them but honestly it might just take
someone else to make you realize how
miniscule this problem is or how many
other reasons there are to be happy it's
very easy to kind of get caught in that
loop when you're just thinking about
things around in your head over and over
and over again you gotta get out and
someone can catch it and turn it into
something beautiful that was weird I
think it means anything like origami no
dish okay now if opening up to people
doesn't work and i would suggest
breaking out of your cycle this could be
the cycle of friends you're hanging
around with or just the way that you are
at the moment perhaps you've just got a
very rigid schedule that is kind of
boring and making you feel upset and
down so try something new break out of
that cycle and you might find new
emotions coming in go online go on
meetup com see what free meetups there
are around your area maybe you just need
to talk to someone who has similar
interests you perhaps you're lucking in
that or maybe you want to try a new
hobby maybe you want to find something
that really interests you and that you
can get creative out there with for me I
just kind of like jam my ukulele and I
always feel better after that even
though I'm not very good at ukulele but
being good doesn't matter going out and
doing something different even just
going to an exhibition or a workshop or
a meet-up your meet new people and they
can help you remember just how beautiful
the world really it's just so
interesting other people are and how to
be happy it sounds strange but sometimes
you do just need to be reminded how to
be happy another one that really really
helps me is to help other people try and
make them happy this might seem really
hard and perhaps you'll have to do it
after you've taken a few other steps so
you're already kind of climbing the
ladder
but it really really helps because at
first by helping people with their
problems it kind of distracts you from
your own problems but then you realize
later on they're actually that happiness
they're feeling you feel it too and
you've helped that seeing them smile and
reminding yourself that you can smile
too and actually you did that you are a
good person you were lovely person
they're a lovely person everyone's
lovely everything's nice just smile but
it sounds so hippie I'm trying not to be
here be I'm so happy right now I thought
well isn't awesome please so that it is
and it's very hard to remember that when
you're all kind of filled in this dark
fog you just got to do this small steps
to clear it the whole reason why i
started youtube well but from being
bored in my bedroom was to start a
community to have people talk to me to
have me talk to you to find out about
people around the whole word world and
yeah just form a community so if any of
you are feeling down or upset i really
would like to see that we can help each
other out and that's what our community
is all about we're there for each other
we can help each other out we can make
it to the smile we can bounce off each
other we can laugh with each other and
that's also why i'm doing a lot more
live streams and things because it's
great to see who do that when i do the
live streams you talk to each other
instead of just focusing on me and
that's lovely i just think that's
awesome if you have any problems please
feel free to talk to someone in the
community about it or get in touch with
me my links are in description below you
can send me a message on facebook tumblr
anything i'm here for you we're all here
for you are all one big family while
we're on the topic of happiness i would
just like to say I'm really really quick
thank you but it shouldn't be quick it
should be long I should go on forever
about how awesome awesome people are but
I just want to say a quick thank you to
hey all of you guys when I put that
robot video up I was so good
and I just yeah I was worried about
telling you my actual feelings about
things but you're all absolutely lovely
and I was really pleasantly surprised
and my mood just was like oh boosted
maybe feel good about humanity again and
I was like yay people also I've been
going out a lot I went to a YouTube
workshop where I lovely girl called Ella
just came up to me and was like hey
wanna go for a pint and I was like okay
and now I read quite a few like new
friends and it's lovely and I really did
not expect that to happen so I want to
say thank you Ella for being so lovely
and just yeah coming up to me when I
didn't know anyone else at that workshop
you can check out her channel here oh
yeah Emily going and I want to say thank
you to my housemate and all my other
friends at university whenever i'm sad i
know we can just go and see them
whenever i just want a good time they're
always there it is really nice to be
around such lovely people sounds really
weird I should tell them this in person
I will show them this video afterwards
yeah you're all wonderful people and I
couldn't ask to be around anyone nice oh
really so thanks for being you you're
all awesome dances as well just thought
I'd throw that in there thank you 2d
eggs Dutch who even though you're so far
away you always email me asking me how I
am checking up on me even if I'm
terrible terrible at replying I just
think it's awesome how far where we are
about how we never forget each other and
that also goes for Amy and Laura some of
you will remember Laura my old housemate
here in Canada who I still get in touch
with and you are awesome awesome awesome
Amy's my very long time best friend who
moved to Scotland a few years ago and we
saw stay in touch as well it is crazy
how when you actually meet people that
you click with your eyes friends it
doesn't matter what happens and that's
lovely another reason to be happy maybe
that's my other tip say thank you to
people remind yourself and remind them
why they make you happy why you're lucky
to have them in your life anyway i hope
this raise your spirits please be happy
I'm so sorry this is so cheesy
kind of hippie and stuff being happy is
cool right its goods and I just want to
kind of give you my positive vibes today
because I'm clearing them I'm feeling
them and hopefully I can like put them
through the blends and now they've just
landed on your face and then they're
going into their face holes you see them
we probably don't because they're going
inside your holes and then they're going
to absorb and become wrong with your
blood your blood your blood and your
particles and here what am i doing I've
lived there evening by what is life
without taking risks would you rather be
comfortable and it's the same chapter
over and over again or would you like to
go on adventures and make new chapters
in your life the answer that question is
entirely up to you and I am not judging
either way and neither should anyone
else